obviously man you got up against
uh of the best at 147 yeah that's what
the [ __ ] you doing fighting that was
spin that was saying
but look i mean no one else wanted to
step up you know you too i didn't
believe you
no one else
it was it was a weight issue it was uh
yeah the
size the size i could tell that but god
lead mikey you didn't show composure i
know you heard even your dad and your
uncle
had thought about even pulling you out
closer to like the later it was like in
the eighth round when my dad and my
brother were you know pretty concerned
yeah rightfully so and that's they're
not doing they're good they're
they're they're you know protecting
they're trying to you know protect what
happened
not her but they just seen a lot a lot
of you know
you didn't look nice no i didn't i was
never really hurt honestly i never got
stunned
never got hurt it was about they saw
that arrow was
coming on stronger and stronger and
maybe trying to stop me trying to look
for the stoppage
so they asked me in the corner hey how
do you feel because you know we don't
want you getting hurt we don't want you
getting punishment
and it looks worse than it really was he
looked worse than it was i told him i'm
fine i'm not hurt he never hurt me
um i'll do better this next upcoming
round so you can see
so they saw me the next few rounds and i
was doing better and they
let me continue my fight you know um but
yeah i mean at the time no one wanted to
get in the ring with arrow
when you trust [ __ ] he fought that
[ __ ] do you want to do no
running
or nothing we were there and and i would
do it again
i i would i would jump in there again
i've been i've been
feeling better yeah because i've been
carrying the weight more uh
better now so i think i would do better
we made some i had no idea
that was good that blew my mind yeah i
mean that night then it made me remember
sizing [ __ ]
no look that's right that [ __ ] the the
the the
size the you know advantage that he has
you know he he is taller and a bigger
man naturally
but i can use defense i can use speed
i can do other things unfortunately that
night i was not able to
really put it together i i made some
mistakes probably
now looking back i probably made some
mistakes i rehydrated a little too much
on fighting that i was a little too
heavy slow i got tired i felt sluggish
you know so i wouldn't do that again
when i fought jesse vargas this last
year i didn't do that i i thought i had
a more comfortable weight
listen to your where i could be you know
to your body yeah just
comfortable speed quickness and that's
what i did
i fall out better he's a tough tough guy
tough guy
he's a big dude he's tough but we fought
him a little differently you know i
like i said i listened to my body you
know i fought more comfortable i didn't
rehydrate too much you know when i
fought aero we did
you know we thought you know we should
gain more weight so we don't have so
much such a huge disadvantage
yeah but i mean he fought great he
fought a great fight he's a terrific
fighter
he has great timing great footwork you
know he can manage the distance and
everything i mean
he's goliath now so anybody wants to see
somebody give him a good fight
so when you go live it's hard for people
people want to see you
push you push i would i would love to
get you know
one or two good wins and and try to
challenge him again
you